[Music]
these are three wonderful films they're
different but similar in certain ways
which we'll cover um but star wars is
telling me a little bit about how each
of these projects came together yeah i
made my film greyhound uh in partnership
with ghetto film school for the
2001 freeze film award
um it was a really dope fellowship that
i did and they basically gave us this
prompt to make a film about change
and as you'll see
uh it's very small film about
essentially about me getting ready for
the college when i was a young boy
and all the change that comes along with
that uh all the fear all the anxiety all
the excitement
of knowing
that you're about to kind of become an
adult and knowing that you're gonna
leave your home and when you come back
it's never gonna be the same
and
uh tj to my left uh is a fantastic
fantastic producer a very close friend
of mine and i met her during my year of
project involvement in 2020
um
middle of cocon baby so that's how you
do it um and uh she and i did not work
together because she didn't care for my
talents at the time
but i developed yeah
well i convinced her with my work ethic
and charm
uh and we have since worked together
and she made it happen for me so i'm
grateful for it
so the real story is
that
um they sent me a text message and said
hey
very cryptic like i need to i want to
talk to you about something i was like
oh okay so he calls me and he's like hey
um
he's like
not really just not not making me not
coherent
and
he's like
like i need some money for this film and
i'm like out of all the people you know
like i'm the one who looks like i'm
doing the best to write a check for this
um and it was near the holidays like in
my life it wasn't the most um
opportune time to write a check
but if you know beyonce you know that
he is so talented and i don't even think
you told me what the film was about
before i said yes i just i tried to i
said i said can i send you the script
first and she and she said yeah you can
send it to me and i'll pull up my phone
and send out the script and i already
got a cash out for the for the full
budget of the film so
she's a real one
so i believe our short dear mom is the
only short produced in project involved
this is a product of all 2021 short film
and so all of the core collaborators we
all met in this program and in this
fellowship and it was all happening
virtually in the zoom space which was
kind of terrifying right it's like folks
you've never met in person and we're
doing this work that is so vulnerable
we're trying to tell the best story
possible but i got so lucky with this
team i mean everybody involved really
wanted to be there really wanted to
fight to tell the best story possible
and so our writer charmaine who is here
brought us this really beautiful concept
about a family navigating pain on the
day that tupac passes away in the 90s
and so that is the world in which our
film takes place so i'm telling this i
guess period story is tonight it's
period right now yes
telling this period story and even
prepping that in the virtual space with
like these new friends that you've met
in the virtual space was scary but um i
think coming onto that set we all just
like locked in and created something
we're all very proud of so we're happy
to be here and to share the word
so soak was my actual thesis of my usc
but
initially i saw i wanted to tell the
story about the complexity of the family
um and having grown up in south korea i
wanted i thought i had to shoot in l.a
and so i was trying to write a story
about a supporting american family and i
was struggling
and started rewriting the story all over
again flew to south korea um over
thanksgiving break and missed all my
classes and just started prepping my
movie there and two months later one
month later we shot the film
[Applause]
um yeah and i'm curious a little bit if
you want to talk about sort of what
aspects of
sort of project involved yeah i think um
i think it taught me not to be afraid to
pick up the song and ask people for
money
i think it also um
i mean it really has my network of
creatives has really expanded
especially to someone like me who
um didn't go to film school and isn't
necessarily the best of networking and
meeting people in the real world this
gave me a really really amazing
opportunity to meet just like world
class creatives who are also just writer
guys and i tj is just one of them but i
have a lot of friends from project
involved that i really love and i really
go to
uh for everything creative or otherwise
and so that's been the biggest thing is
feeling like i have a foundation of
people who are really about this
um i think for me when i first moved to
la almost eight years ago film
independent was one of the first
organizations that i was encouraged to
join
and before i even got into project
involved it became a little bit of a
community like i would go to the events
i would go to the
um
educational
series and so when i got into project
involve um echoing beyonce's sentiments
like i didn't go to film school so
that kind of became my film community it
was kind of like my gym in a sense my
film school in a sense and so
um i met so many great people out of
there i also
learned how to do a lot with a little if
you know you know
um
and so
i think for me it's organization
organizations like this especially that
reach to people who are underrepresented
in the community are so important
because
there's not a lot of that and if you
don't have work organizations like this
it's really
it's a lot more difficult um to do
things in this industry so i'm extremely
grateful
same here i mean walking away from
project involved with the real community
i also did not go to film school i went
to drama school so i have a beautiful
collection of actors i know and like
talking about work from that perspective
but
i too would find myself like i want to
like talk to an idea or like i want to
make something or i just need folks i
can like tap in with and they'll sit
with me in the mud and really get dirty
with the work and so it was really right
it was exciting to walk away from this
program with collaborators and with
friends who like want it and love it and
they're like call me with the nerdy
questions like i want to talk about it
you know and so that's been so special
and then same here with film
independence the organization they've
just been so supportive and even giving
us spaces like this to share our work
and to talk about our work at the dga
like this is not normal or casual and i
think we're all i would say grateful to
be a part of this and to you know be
collaborative with some independent so
that i'm really grateful for
lovely
it's a great commercial project
um so i'm still in the program so we'll
see how
no i
just like everyone said i met so many
great collaborators and i having never
been in a program like this it was like
i didn't know it was possible to have
such a support system and like just to
find out like
oh we don't have to worry about camera
packages what like
from that to um also being able to meet
other
creators but also specifically asian
american creators that are um
in the program i think
film independent does a very good job or
project involved does a really good job
making sure
to like find those people in those
voices
so yeah that's it let's talk a little
about the films that are going to be
presented tonight you will have to
imagine and then realize what we're
talking about later
[Music]
but i'm going to do i'm going to do my
best to involve you in in these films
that you've already seen i want to talk
a little bit about the visual language
that you all developed because they
think that these three shorts have
really you know very distinctive um
visual voices
um
the greyhound we have in black and white
in silk i feel like there's an image if
you can all imagine with me of a neon
sign you'll see this later actually
that really sticks with you a lot of
good muted colors and then really you
know very striking bright images and
then winter and i were even just talking
a little bit about the color palette um
in dear mama talk to me about how you
developed these these visual identities
for the films and how you matched it to
the to the stories you're trying to tell
yeah um my film is is in black and white
um it's one of many black microphones
i've made it's the only one i've made
black and white on purpose
with like intention and artistic merit
um i think for me i this is a story that
essentially represents a time capsule
for me um and when you watch like those
old black and white films from the 30s
the 40s the 50s which i watch a lot of
um they have this like otherworldly
quality to them right they don't feel
nearly as immediate as the color films
of the 60s and 70s and then obviously
later and so you really feel transported
when you watch like an old humphrey
bogart movie or something like that and
so for me i wanted to tap into that
because the story is in my mind kind of
like an old removed film um and so i
wanted to like i wanted people to watch
and feel like they were being
transported to a time before
uh
and not only that
it is
uh though it's technically a time
capsule film takes place in 2000s
um i wanted i couldn't really i didn't
have the time or energy or skill to like
really commit to that and so having it
be black and white um i think for me was
a way to like
just like capture that feeling and not
just that but like black folk look
really beautiful in black and white um
like like it's just gorgeous to look at
um
and it's one of the few i think like
visual or color languages
that like um from the get-go just
benefits black folk i think like cinema
is always in the cameras we use and the
color package we use have always been
used to benefit white foam
and to just like just to like put a
filter on and be like damn these people
look gorgeous was like really important
to me so that's that's a big part of it
there yeah it's transported for sure i'm
gonna jump to hannah because she keeps
having to go by so yeah
thank you um
so with so
it's kind of nice having to
uh
um
so the first thing that i told my dp was
that i wanted the film to kind of have
this sense of being under water
um because it's about this pressure
that's coming at our main character from
all sides so we did a lot of tests with
different filters and then we landed on
gluing
like stockings silk stockings on the
lenses to have that like case effect and
i think
that plus being in the sort of like red
lights motel district with all the neon
lights really created that like hazy
blurry color effect that we were going
for so
yeah
i don't know we uh other than that it
was just capturing what was there
yeah beautiful
oh silk stock it's like that's awesome
that's
um so
similarly to what you were saying about
black bodies and black skin on camera
that is also something i'm very
passionate about like if we're going to
shoot black people it needs to be done
right and so i talked to my dp because
we're in 1996 and i said i want the film
to have like a texture and color
that you almost feel like we're shooting
on a camera that they would have in
their home in 1996. so there's like a
moodiness to the image that you're
immediately like transported into a
different time you're like this is where
are we and i want to learn more about
that and i also wanted us to live in a
brown color palette so like all of the
colors are like browns and nudes and
chocolate and i don't know i wanted to
create this warm brown
world as well as not being afraid to go
dark with the color story i think
sometimes when you go dark you lose dark
brown skin and i really wanted us to
fight to find what does dark and moody
look like on that skin tone and how can
we really make that shine and feel
interesting and watching films that kind
of play with those techniques some of
like pariah the feature is a film i love
and i love how dark and moody they went
without ever losing those faces in that
skin tone is that something we wanted to
try to achieve with this story as well
and um
yeah i'm really happy with the results i
think you know that you'll see
um tell me a little bit more about your
senses of place i feel like um each each
of your films is really settled and
worried about obviously
we have some
far away journeys but also i feel like
you know it's in graham it's really sort
of an ode
um to ellie and so from a producer
perspective in your direct weather
perspectives um how did you build up
that sort of really subtle sense of
geography in each of your pieces
yeah i think for me um
i was i was raised in this city i was
one of the few people raised in los
angeles
and
um i remember growing up feeling like i
knew the city like the back of my hand
and then you go to college and you learn
so much more about the world
and you come back to the city and you
realize you nothing
and not just that but like especially in
the film industry there's a layer of
like of this industry about success that
is invisible to the naked eye right most
people in the city don't even know it
exists and so that was like a big part
of like
of of of the film of like trying to
remember what la felt like before
it feels like it does now
um
and
yeah i it's not it's something that i'm
really
intrigued by and i want to keep
exploring because i still feel like i
don't know the city at all i still feel
like i'm learning my hometown so yeah
how do you location scout for them
um and i trusted him immensely and i
think when you watch it uh
it almost feels like a love letter to
los angeles that's um
whether it's the
this is crazy i'm just writing it the
shot in the car
or you're looking through the sunroom
before it's the end when he's getting
out it's like
it's just in because it's so beautifully
shy black and white um is definitely a
love letter to los angeles yeah yeah
um well we had a challenge right we were
a copic project involved short so the
rules were one location two to three
characters max and we are also in l.a
short so it was like this question of
how do we ground ourselves in 1996 la
without actually going out into la yep
and i think a lot of that dealt with one
choosing the right house choosing a
house where i felt like we could shoot
it from all these long interesting
angles to try to make the most out of
that space but also in the production
design that's where i think we really
grounded ourselves in this in this era
so even me like going through family
photos and like in my deck there's a
picture of me and my mom when i was like
three and it was like i wanted to feel
like this or like that purple comforter
that every black person had in their
house
in the mid 90s like we need that are
like there's a wicker headboard that the
production designer like fought to find
because i was like whisker is black
people in the night he's like
i don't care what god it's like it's
true so that was like the work for us of
like making that house grounding that
house in the time and in the city and
trusting that people would like trust us
and trust that this is really an la
story even though we're not outside in
l.a
um for me so
so was the first film i shot in south
korea and although i grew up there
going back to shoot a movie you kind of
see it through a whole
new different set of eyes so
you know like the dirty alleyway
suddenly seems so cinematic
and like you start to appreciate all
these things like that the tacky
tablecloth at the old restaurant like oh
this color is so great and so really
just making sure that
that we captured those details was
important i feel and then also it was a
lot of
just like the people like in korea at
night you see all these like
drunk men
being rowdy and laughing and eating and
um
we hired extras to have that like i
think they
are a huge part of making that
environment and just like people smoking
on the street and stuff like that um so
yeah yeah i was before watching them
like i was honestly struggling this was
a big part of what i was saying
about my film graham like i was really
trying to figure out what this city was
again and i felt like i was trying to
find people and things and projects and
vibes that like were gonna help me grow
as an artist
and i was slaving away like the most
classic hollywood job
um and i was just tired and i was burnt
out and
you know this really came along like the
best time of my life and it really just
helped me reshape i think
everything my whole interesting process
the kind of people i wanted to work with
the kind of projects i wanted to do
um and i think it's giving me just like
a lot of confidence i mean kind of like
winter was saying we were in a all of us
that aren't a covid um our coded classes
um and we were the very first one kogan
hit in the middle of our program right
before we were going to film
um and so if anything else has taught me
just how to be so resilient how to be
creative and how to come up with
um you know
really really cool solutions
yeah resourceful
um
so i actually applied for project above
years ago um as foreign executive track
our developer network i was marketing i
thought that's really what i wanted to
do
um and then
i didn't get in of course
um i got some more experience under my
belt i did a couple of series and shorts
and i was like oh production is really
what i want to do
so i reapplied in that time when i
reapplied i'd also
realized that it was time for me to move
on from corporate world and really
pursue production and writing um being
creative full-time and so
the day that i gave notice at the oprah
winfrey network was the day i found out
i got the project involved
[Music]
and so
through the pandemic and working on so
many different projects and with so many
different people
people
in project involve and also outside of
project evolve really just equipped me
um with the experience that i needed to
get like those bigger jobs that
i wasn't able to get before and so
um now i'm in post-production on a
documentary that's premiering um on
comcast in october and
um i came back to help project involve
for this
[Applause]
i'm currently writing a pilot and
also pitching an unscripted series so
fabulous yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
okay um
uh similarly i was in la
trying to figure out how to be a
creative i didn't know much about
production when i landed because i had
an acting background but i knew the one
thing i always said is like i have these
images in my head and if i could just
learn the craft of it i think they could
be moving and so i just hit the ground
running like working in the digital
space producing and directing web series
and then i was really fortunate to be
asked to produce a feature called
jezebel alongside the director and so
that really was like a part of my film
school journey of like okay how do you
make the logo budget feature like what
does it take like what is the director
really doing on that set with their
actors like what does it look like in
real time so that i was really fortunate
to get that experience directing my
first short film which was
such a learning experience for me as
well
um and then i was also working in the
digital space at conde nast so i was
doing like a lot of celebrity editorial
videos so it felt like i was learning a
lot about independent really strong
filmmaking and then also working with
these big name talents and learning what
it meant to navigate a talent like that
and all the folks that come with them
and kind of having these two experiences
happening simultaneously and i knew
project involves fellowship i wanted to
do i knew i wanted to be connected to
other filmmakers and so i felt like when
i applied and got in it was just like
the right moment i had just left kanye
similarly i was like walking away from
the corporate thing like i want to make
movies and then this came and i was like
we're making money like let's go
um and so yeah it was it's been a real
blessing the film's doing really well
and it's helping me quite a bit i've
been able to get my reps um i'm taking
meetings for a few features right now i
just shout out on a pepsi commercial so
i'm trying to get that commercial
bundy
just trying to get all the things going
right
so yeah
great
you're in the midst of it yeah that's a
different question for you
yes the
project involved i think i was going a
little bit so crazy
after i graduated and it was a pandemic
and it was mostly just like writing
writing writing
about feature script
um
and then finally like this gave me a
chance to reconnect with the crew actors
and feedback on set and honestly like i
was really nervous because i felt like i
had become rusty over the past two years
but it was
like such a good feeling just to be like
there with the dp and your actors and
child listening
um
so yeah it's
really grateful for the experience and
um we're still impulse for my project
month
project but also
developing a tv show and
also hopefully
my future me
fabulous
i'm so glad we had a chance to talk
beforehand actually no it was nice to
learn a little bit more about you and
just as artists and where you're at and
how project involved has served you um
and tease your films that we're about to
see so uh
[Applause]
[Music]
you